WIL WILLIS:
Bladesmiths, now it's
time to send you back
to your home forges
to recreate this iconic weapon--
J. Neilson's war scythe.
DOUG MARCAIDA: Next up,
I'll be pre-testing--
[laughs maniacally] --J.
Neilson's war scythe.
WIL WILLIS: This war scythe was
personally created by our very
own Beast from the East.
This war scythe is
a menacing variation
on a centuries-old peasants'
weapon from Middle Age Europe.
Ready for battle at
a moment's notice,
farmers would take their
scythes from work to war
during uprisings, riots,
or calls to battle.
This weapon uses a long shaft
to generate massive power
to cut down enemies, while
its lethal sharp point
could be thrust into
infantry and cavalry.
This multifaceted
scythe features a fork
opposite the blade as a
brutal piercing element
and a small blade at
the bottom of the pole
to finish off an opponent.
Scythes are represented
in pop culture
as sinister and ominous
weapons symbolizing death
and is most notoriously
wielded by the grim reaper.
DOUG MARCAIDA: It was a very
interesting weapon because you
got a scythe and you get a
blade-- a curved blade, here--
on the edges on the outside.
Have I ever tested
anything like that?
No.
And when I did, pure heaven.
WIL WILLIS: The kill test
master, Doug Marcaida.
[maniacal laughter]
Yeah, he just looks
like a murderer.
DOUG MARCAIDA: So
this is a weapon,
if you're not careful or
are unfamiliar with it,
you can actually hurt yourself.
When you've got
blades everywhere
facing the wrong way-- you've
got the front, the back here,
and the hook blade, and
everything else-- you really
have to be used to
handling weapons
and knowing where
everything dangerous,
everything sharp is at.
Every time you swing, you
make sure that you don't
swing it back to cut yourself.
To test J. Neilson's war
scythe, because we didn't have
another weapon just
like it, we had
to make a mockup of it that
was similar to the dimensions
that J. presented.
It was very interesting.
It was very revealing on how to
fight with something like this
without cutting yourself.
As you're coming forward,
there's a blade right there,
so I got to be careful of that.
As I'm going there, there's
another blade over here.
Just wielding that
thing, it really
gave me a chance to actually
learn to adjust and create
a movement that
keeps me safe, but at
the same time do maximum damage
to what's in front of me.
[dramatic music]
All right, Alex.
The balance is light, allowing
it to be a very fast weapon
that you can use little
hand, long-handed,
or for close quarters.
Your weapon will kill.
All right, Trevor.
Trick or treat?
- Treat.
Indeed.
[rock music]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Trevor.
The tip alone penetrates
deeply into the gut.
And the edges here
are sharp enough to,
well, make it lose his head.
Overall, sir, it will kill.
Thank you, sir.
J. NEILSON: All right, smiths.
Welcome to the strength test,
the dreaded coffin challenge.
I'm going to take these bones
and beat them repeatedly
into the blade of your scythe.
And Alex, you're locked
in and ready to go first.
You ready?
Yep.
That's what I want to hear.
[dramatic music]
Alex, you survived.
Good job.
The only issue I had-- you
have some slight rolling
on the edge.
And the head of this moves,
so it's not secure anymore.
But your edge held up great.
Good job.
Thank you.
How are you feeling, Trevor.
- Pretty good, right now.
- Good?
We'll see how you
feel in a minute.
[rock music]
Nice job, Trevor-- held up well.
Your edge is still
good, nice and sharp.
Everything's still tight.
Good job.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths.
This is the sharpness
test, the zombie surprise.
To test the edge of your weapon,
I'm going to take your scythe
and cut through this rope,
thereby releasing a surprise.
(LAUGHING) All right.
Alex, you're up first.
You ready?
Certainly.
[rock music]
[bleep]
DOUG MARCAIDA: All right, Alex.
It cut easily on the rope.
When you're puncturing this,
it cuts through and slices.
It'll cut.
- Thank you.
- All right, Trevor.
Your turn, sir.
You ready?
Hell yeah.
[thunder rolls]
[rock music]
DOUG MARCAIDA:
All right, Trevor.
The edge that you
have here lends itself
to cut the rope much easier.
When you're
puncturing, it starts
to cut all the way through.
Overall, sir, it will cut.
Thank you.
WIL WILLIS: All
right, bladesmiths.
You guys have done fantastic
work, but only one of you
can be the "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And that champion is--
Trevor.
Congratulations.
You are the new "Forged
in Fire" champion.
Alex, unfortunately, your
blade took some damage
in our strength test.
You did great work, my friend.
But at this time, I have to ask
you to please exit the forge.
ALEX: Ultimately, it came
down to the construction.
I think I definitely
made a blade
that can intimidate anyone.
WIL WILLIS: Well,
Trevor, the judges all
agree you made a damn near
perfect war scythe, which
has earned you the title
of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Come on forward and
shake our hands.
TREVOR: I won!
Woo!
I think the biggest thing I
learned was to keep on trying.
If something doesn't go your
way, don't get upset about it.
Just keep moving forward.
This was a perfect
Halloween experience.
I feel like I just
went trick-or-treating,
and I got a pillowcase
full of candy.
[theme music]
[spooky laughter, scream]